salut aujourd'hui on va parler de
quelque chose d'un petit peu passionnant
qui sont les rappels automatiques combes
semaine dans le cerveau un petit peu
comme l'application rappel sur le
téléphone portable j'avais jamais
vraiment pensé à vous parler de ça et à
l'issue d'un spectacle à lyon au mois de
mars dernier ça remonte un petit peu il
ya guillaume qui m'en a parlé qui m'a
envoyé un mail à ce propos l'idée est la
suivante c'est que quand on fait quelque
chose quand on se retrouve à un endroit
il faudrait que dans notre cerveau est
un processus qui fasting rappelle toi tu
ça c'est parti générique pour bien
commencer cette vidéo je vais répondre à
deux questions que vous me posez
beaucoup un petit peu partout en ce
moment la première c'est que le prochain
live aura lieu ce dimanche 28 à 18
heures je l' ai beaucoup bossé donc il
devrait changer dès de live précédent
j'ai un peu le trac et la deuxième c'est
toutes les questions que vous me posez à
propos du livre toutes les réponses vous
pouvez les trouver dans la vidéo que
j'ai fait à ce sujet qui est dans la
description concernant cette fameuse
mémoire ya un truc qu'on appelle la
madeleine de proust qui est que quand on
sent une odeur quand on entend un son
alors on a une masse de souvenirs
accroché à sa qui peuvent remonter même
des choses qu'on pensait avoir oublié
depuis longtemps c'est bon signe ça veut
dire qu'on peut faire une connexion
entre quelque chose d'environnemental et
un souvenir donc potentiellement on
pourrait créer artificiellement une
action mémorielle liées à un
environnement par exemple j'arrive
devant chez moi il faut que je pense à
faire ça dans les faits c'est pas aussi
simple il ya une technique que ceux qui
ont mon âge et au delà connaissent on
appelle la technique du noeud dans le
mouchoir pourquoi je vous le donne en
mille et mille
est ce qu'il s'agit de faire un os dans
son choix propre de préférence le
mouchoir
c'est une technique de mnémotechnique
pour se rappeler de faire quelque chose
qui a été très populaire au début du 19e
siècle
on retrouve même des références à sable
dans des romans dans des livres pour se
rappeler de devoir faire quelque chose
en faisait un noeud à son mouchoir
mettez dans sa poche ce qui fait que
quand on sortait son mouchoir on voyait
le noeud et on savait plus ce qui était
prévu mais on savait qu'on avait oublié
de faire quelques choses n'ont encore
pas mal de souvenirs au monde
mais quand même quelque chose
d'intéressant à ça c'est la rupture de
l'habitude mais ça on va y revenir après
parce que william plan il ya une
séquence et vidéos sont écrites on
dirait pas on se prépare même à petite
bouteille d'eau pour essayer de bien
parler bon l'idée le secret c'est quand
même de créer un ancrage psychologique
c'est quelque chose qu'on a vu sur la
chaîne par rapport aux émotions pour
ressentir une émotion particulière au
sommet dans un état particulier mais on
pourrait essayer de l'appliquer à de la
mémoire le problème c'est que l'ancrage
psychologique tel qu'on l'entend c'est
quelque chose qui se travaille dans le
temps alors que là si c'est pas quelque
chose de récurrent forcément ça
fonctionne moins bien mais si c'est
quelque chose de récurrent alors on peut
faire cet exercice là c'est à dire
fermez les yeux se poser dans une
une émotion un peu calme un petit peu
neutre il faut se visualiser en train de
faire cette chose là si par exemple à
chaque fois j'oublie de fermer la porte
de mon garage l'idée de vivre cette
scène mentalement souvent dans un état
de relaxation de me voir mettre la main
sur la poignée de la porte et en faisant
ça d'imaginer une grande clé lumineuse
imaginaire plus je vais faire ça plus
veut ancrer cette association d'idées
plus dans la vraie vie quand je vais
toucher la poignée de la porte alors
cette les me reviendra et je me
rappellerai de fermer la porte
ça c'est bien donc pour les trucs
récurrent mais pour les trucs
ponctuelles le premier problème c'est
qu'il vient du fait d'être dans
l'instant présent ça aussi on va y
revenir avant la fin de la vidéo
mais il faut être vraiment dans
l'instant présent pour pouvoir apprécier
en fait les stimulations autour de nous
et environnemental et faire revenir
quelque chose de lié parce que si on est
concentré sur autre chose dans sa tête
construit un peu bouffé par son mental
et par ses idées alors on n'est pas
assez attentifs à ce qui se passe autour
d'eux s'ils voulaient d'ailleurs une c4
je vous ferai une vidéo sur l'instant
présent diplôme mois dans les
commentaires si ça vous tente donc je
crois que meilleure méthode pour les
choses ponctuelles ça reste de faire une
rupture d'habitude donc je vous ai dit
précédemment c'est à dire quelque chose
qui ne devrait pas être là où qui ne
devrait pas être comme ça et le fait de
le constater ça va nous ramener aux
pourquoi on a fait ça au départ ma l'amf
a bien un truc tout bête pour reprendre
l'exemple de guillaume qui se posaient
la question pour sa boîte à gants et
bien guillaume quand tu vas dans ta
voiture je pense qu habituellement tu
gardes ton monte oh sur toi ou tu me
mets sur le siège passager pas te dire
de le mettre dans la boîte alliance avec
un petit peu galère par contre tu peux
le mettre dans ton corps tu vas perdre
quelques secondes à faire sa mue au
moment où tu vas descendre de la voiture
tu vas forcément chercher ton manteau il
va être dans le coffre tu vas te
rappeler qu'il a mis dans le coffre donc
il va trés après que tu l'a mis dans le
coffre pour penser apprendre quelque
chose à la boîte à gants je pense que le
système est clair ou pas donc je vais
prendre un deuxième exemple il est
toujours basé sur le génialissime ne
dans le mouchoir en fait si vous devez
absolument faire quelque chose dans
votre journée que vous avez peur
d'oublier et que vous avez une montre
dont vous vous servez vous pouvez
arrêter la trotteuse de la montre et
laisser sa sueur midi tout pile comme ça
à chaque fois vous allez regarder
l'heure vous allez voir qu'elle montrait
bloqué vous allez vous rappelez de
pourquoi elle s'est bloquée vous allez
penser à faire cette action un autre
exemple avec le téléphone portable je
change mon code mon code de
déverrouillage jeu mais la date du jour
parce que sinon à force je veux aussi
oublier les codes temporaire que je mets
ce qui fait qu'à chaque fois que je me
prends un vent violent déverrouiller mon
téléphone je me rappelle que j'ai changé
temporairement et je me rappelle de
pourquoi j'ai fait ça et enfin pour
terminer j'aimerais prendre la situation
à l inverse c'est à dire quand on se
souvient pu de si on a fait quelque
chose ou pas je prenais l'exemple de la
porte de garage je suppose que ça vous
est déjà arrivé de vous dirai ce que
j'ai pensé à faire ça en partant ou est
ce que j'ai fait ça aujourd'hui c'est
très très agaçant parce que des fois ça
nous oblige à
revenir en arrière pour constater qu'on
avait tout bien fait que j'ai une astuce
pour ça si vous voulez vous souvenir il
suffit au moment de faire l'action d'y
prêter une réelle attention pour ma part
vraiment c'est un truc je ne sais jamais
si j'ai fermé à clé ou pas donc
maintenant à chaque fois que je ferme
une porte à clé en partant je me regarde
faire réellement et jeudi à voix haute
en chuchotant parce que sinon le voisin
vous commencez à me prendre pour un ouf
je dis je suis en train de fermer la
porte et rien que le fait de faire ça je
prête assez d'attention à l'action pour
que ça devienne un vrai souvenir dans la
mémoire épisodique et que je m'en
souvienne si je me pose la question dans
la journée très utile je vous recommande
de faire ça quand vous fermerez la porte
de chez moi
rappelez vous vous lavez fermé voilà et
en parlant de mémoire et d'oubli comme
d'habitude n'oubliez pas de cliquer et
de vous abonner rendez vous samedi matin
à 11 heures